-You look gorgeous.
Thank you so much
for coming to the show.
-My pleasure.
-It's so nice to meet you.
I was doing a little reading up
about you, and I --
-What were you reading?
-I was reading the --
[ Laughter ]
No, great stuff, great stuff.
I read that your mom knew
you were gonna be a star.
-Yeah, yeah.
-At a young age.
You were in front of the TV --
-You about to get me
in trouble, Jimmy.
-No, no, no.
-No, you are,
because it's been a thing.
She saw me watching TV,
watching "Soul Train,"
and she said I was dancing.
The contention is whether
I was 2 or 4.
I've been saying 4,
and I get home, and she's like,
"Danielle, you're on the TV,
and you're telling the people
the wrong thing. It's 2."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "My bad."
Sorry, Mom.
[ Both laugh ]
-So you were 2?
-So somewhere between 2 and 4.
-So you're 2 years old,
watching Don Cornelius
on "Soul Train"...
-And I was grooving
and grooving, and she said,
"That baby needs to be
in performing arts."
So she put me in dance,
and it was my first medium.
And I started doing theater
and just moving into
all the other things.
Experimental stuff,
performing arts,
you know, just everything.
And so it's just been a part
of my life since I was a kid.
-Yeah, and so I go,
that's amazing, I love that.
You watch "Soul Train,"
it gets you, and you go,
"That's my acting bug."
But then I heard that you
watched a film like a hundred
times in a row, 'cause it was --
-It's not a hundred!
That's an exaggeration.
[ Laughter ]
-Mom?
Mom, are you watching, Mom?
-No! Don't you --
She don't know!
I was by myself!
[ Laughter ]
-How many times
did you watch this film?
-It was at least like 20 to 30
times the summer it came out.
It was "Lord of the Rings" one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right? Right?
-Now, that's the one.
-When the DVD came out.
-And that was the one.
And that -- you said,
"That's it right there.
This is a film.
This is a masterpiece.
This is what I gotta do."
-Specifically, Gollum.
[ Laughter ]
Andy Serkis as Gollum,
as Smeagol, is just --
you know, it's divine.
It's vocality, it's physicality,
it's all of the things,
and so --
-That performance changed
the game in your head.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you memorized
Gollum's moves and how Gollum --
Can you talk like Gollum?
-Yes.
Yes, I can.
[ Laughter ]
-What would you say as Gollum?
-Well, as Gollum,
when I was on "From Scratch,"
with Zoe Saldana, we would --
I did a song.
I did "Baby Got Back" for her.
[ Laughter ]
As Gollum.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Gollum ] Are you ready?
Because, here we go.
All right, here we go.
♪ I like big butts
and I cannot lie ♪
♪ You other brothers
can't deny ♪
♪ When a girl walks in
with an itty bitty waist ♪
♪ And a round thing
in your face, you get sprung ♪
♪ Want to pull up tough ♪
♪ 'Cause you noticed that butt
was stuffed ♪
♪ Deep in the jeans
she's wearing ♪
♪ I'm hooked,
and I can't stop staring ♪
♪ Oh, baby ♪
♪ I wanna get wit'cha ♪
♪ And take your picture ♪
♪ My homeboys tried to warn me ♪
♪ But that butt you got
make me so -- precious ♪
Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was wondering how you
were gonna do that.
That's what I'm talking about.
Come on.
Thank you for doing that.
-You're welcome.
-It's so fun.
-It's gonna be really hard
to get out of this.
-Oh, my gosh.
Now you're stuck as Gollum
for the rest of --
-Yes, for the rest of the show.
[ Normal voice ]
No, I'm -- I'm back.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm back, I'm back.
-I also heard --
I also heard that before the --
as you were getting
the acting bug, you go, hey --
you -- you became a teacher.
-I did! I taught for four --
no, two years.
Fourth and fifth grade.
-You're so young-looking.
I feel like if you --
-That's a hard thing, Jimmy.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause you're trying to teach,
and they're like, "So, what --
Did you just get out of school?"
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-And I'm like...
-Yeah, "No, I'm an adult."
-"Go sit down."
-Yeah, "Go sit down."
Yeah, exactly.
-So, yeah, it's cool.
-You've been in
so many great projects.
But including "Till,"
you've been nominated
for almost every award.
The reviews are unbelievable.
And I would actually like
to read a couple reviews.
You can plug your ears...
-I will.
-...if you don't want
to hear about yourself.
But, all right, here's somebody
from "The Wrap."
It says, "This magnificent
performance elevates Deadwyler
into the ranks of
the great actors of our time."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is hot, Jimmy.
My...
-It is hot, right?
-My pits are sweating.
-"This is a career-defining
performance that'll likely
lead her to become one of
the most highly sought after
actresses in the business."
From "Collider."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy, you wrote that.
-No, that's for real,
from "Collider."
"Her performance here
is nothing short
of magnificent and powerful."
That's from "Screen Rant."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The last one.
-Okay, finally.
-Whoopi Goldberg was here
on the show, sitting there,
and told me,
"It is the best thing
I've ever seen from an actor."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I watched it,
and I was blown away.
And I go,
"I have to get to know you."
You are unbelievable
in this thing.
It must have been tough
filming this.
-Yeah, it's a difficult thing.
But we had
a beautiful community.
Everything about this movie
was -- was rooted in love.
Chinonye, our director,
all of our producers, they --
We just made sure we were
taking good care of each other.
-Yeah, it's -- it almost
was never made, this movie.
-Yeah, it's taken --
Well, truthfully, 67 years,
considering, in 1955, Mamie Till
wanted the film to be made.
You know, had to deal with,
you know, contention and folks
turning away from doing it.
But then Barbara Broccoli,
Whoopi, all of them,
and Keith Beauchamp,
who was her mentee,
came on and were committed
to getting the film made.
And, finally, we filmed it
in 2021, and here it came,
in '22, and we're still riding.
-Whew! It is --
It's powerful.
It's definitely a story
that needs to be told.
-Most definitely.
-And, you know, I know you want
to keep it light on the set
when you were in between scenes,
and I heard that you would sing.
-Oh, geez.
[ Laughter ]
-I was just -- I just heard
this, and so I go --
-Who?
Who told you?
[ Laughter ]
-Jalyn.
-Jalyn, Whoopi.
-I'm coming for you.
Whoopi?!
Whoopi doesn't know this!
-Yeah, she does.
-Oh.
-Yeah. And so I said
when you come on the show,
I have to ask you about this.
-Okay.
-How do you do --
What's your singing?
-Well, I sing gospel songs.
-Okay.
-One specific gospel song.
-Which one?
-"I Won't Complain."
-Yeah.
You know it?
See? Yeah.
By Reverend Paul Jones.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-So, now and then you'll just --
-And I'm not a gospel singer,
Jimmy.
-No.
But you do it for fun.
-I did it for them.
I did it for Dee Dee and Denise,
who were my hair
and makeup artists, yep.
A lot.
-And how would you perform,
just say, if we were there?
-I -- I --
If we were there?
-Yeah, if we were on set
and in between takes.
-You got a mic?
Oh, yeah.
-And it's old-school.
-I would go, oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Y'all gotta stop
revving me up!
[ Both laugh ]
♪ I have some good days ♪
♪ I've had some hills
to climb ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I've had some weary days ♪
♪ And ♪
♪ Some lonely nights ♪
♪ But when I ♪
♪ When I look around ♪
[ Cheers ]
♪ And ♪
♪ I think things over ♪
You know what?
♪ All of my good days ♪
♪ Outweigh my bad days ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I-I-I-I ♪
♪ I won't complain ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Forever.
I love you forever.
-Jimmy...
-Thank you for doing that.
Thank you for doing that.
-I would sing it
with the thing, but...
-I love you forever.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Danielle Deadwyler
in "Till."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I need Beau's bodies
sent back here.
I can't have him buried
in Mississippi.
-Mississippi won't make
that deal with you.
-Then make them.
I'm sure Mr. Huff can get
Mayor Daley or the Governor
to talk to somebody.
Those people in Mississippi
are trying to dump Beau
in the ground
like he's just another body.
He is my baby.
I need to see him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh.
Danielle Deadwyler!
"Till" is on digital, on demand,
and available on blu-ray.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.